so my Hummer's outside it's a $200,000
car it's lless technically we have
compromises on things I think it's a lot
anyways so these are the keys to my
Hummer it's
$200,000 who here can give me 10 grand
for the Hummer do you think if I went on
the street and went and was like here
are my keys 10 grand can you give me and
they know that I'm actually going to
give them the car what do they do they
figure the out so it's always a
value objection it's not about
finances like until someone shows me
every bank account they have that has no
money in it and that they also don't
have credit cards and they have no
ability cuz they have no hands to go
apply for credit cards and they don't
have a phone to call friends to borrow
money then like it just doesn't help the
easiest example I had for this is